i think failure is bad um i don't think
it's good um but if if if something's
important enough then you you do it even
though the risk of failure is high
um
and and so i think my advice if somebody
wants to start a company is they should
bear in mind that the most likely
outcome is is that it's not going to
work
and they should reconcile themselves to
that
past strong possibility um and they
should only do it if they feel that they
they're they're really compelled to do
it you know right
because it's it's
it's gonna the way starting company
works is like usually in the beginning
it's the very beginning it's kind of fun
um and then it's really hellish for
a number of years you talked about
chewing glass
yeah there's
there's a friend of mine who's a
successful entrepreneur
and uh
started actually his career around the
same time as i did and he has a good
good good phrase his name's bully uh he
said yeah your starting company is like
eating glass and staring into the abyss
and
and you agree with that
generally true um yeah
and and if you don't eat the glass
you're not going to be successful hey
it's evan carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how to deal
with failure to overcome your fear
enjoy
rule number two is embrace the fall with
simon sinek first of all i don't like
the term failure i like the term falling
i think you need
we fail fast well
the problem with the word fail is it's
like the word cancer
right
if you have stage four lung cancer or
stage four liver cancer and you have a
mild melanoma
with a 99.999 chance of you'll be fine
both of those things are called cancer
and the problem is they're not the same
thing and failure's the same is the same
which is failure could be absolutely
catastrophic or it could be a minor
hiccup but the problem is we call it
failure so i think we need to use
different terms right failure i believe
is something we want to avoid but
falling is something that happens
naturally and we want to fall and get
get up more often that's what i think is
fall fall fast and get yourself back up
as opposed to lying on the ground and
complaining right so i i want to embrace
falling because that's that's taking
risks that's trying you only fall when
you push the boundaries right
but the the the the language matters
because it changes our mindset
especially because it's too broad a
definition for failure
so one of the ways we embrace falling
is by when somebody does fall we don't
say what have you done
we go okay try again as leaders
right um or um how can i help you fix it
and we just a little more relaxed about
it and and we don't swoop in and do it
for them right
but rather we go
so in other words we're encouraging
risk-taking we're encouraging people to
try recognizing that they won't lose
their jobs
that
that
especially if you're more junior you
really couldn't do anything that brings
down the firm anyway
and we have to give people the
opportunity to fall and let them either
learn to fix their own problems or guide
them so that so that they can every
single one of us has screwed up a
bazillion times and the only reason we
are where we are today is because
somebody said all right all right you're
an idiot but try again you know
like that's where i know who did it for
me peter and tommy my old boss years and
years and years ago the guy would never
answer any of my questions peter what
should i do what do you think we should
do like
if i knew i wouldn't be asking well what
do you think i think we should do this
then do that the guy never answered a
question and if i screw up he goes
what are you going to do
you know
but i never felt fear that i would get
fired ever
i never felt afraid that my job was on
the line when i screwed up
we have to do that for people rule
number three is let fear sit with you
with lisa nichols over my career
and
i've been in business over 20 years now
[Music]
people from all around the world
students at every level
whether they are
newly into launching their business or
they've been in business themselves for
10 15 years
ask the question how do i overcome fear
i'm about to disrupt you
completely because i am not
going to give you a strategy to overcome
fear
because if i even attempt to give you a
stride and i know we're always looking
at stuff reading things how to overcome
fears they're probably 10 steps to
overcoming fear somewhere out there they
weren't written by me
and i could never write it
because i don't think
you wait to overcome fear to live the
life of your dreams or the one that you
deserve or to blow your own mind
i personally and i'm teaching you from
my
life lessons from what i've studied what
i've applied what i've implemented what
i've fallen from what i've soared from
what i've gotten up from
and
i don't think you focus on learning how
to overcome fear though there are things
that helps to mitigate your fear
information mitigates fear
training and developing your skill set
mitigates fear i teach speaking i love
teaching people how to speak powerfully
not to speak to be great but to speak to
be unforgettable whether you're a
speaker or whether you're a manager
whether you're in retails or network
marketing whatever it is when you open
your mouth you won't be unforgettable
and people always say lisa how do i
overcome the fear of speaking i said
let's not focus
on the fear of speaking because energy
grows where energy goes so let's not
focus on overcoming fear
let's focus on building a muscle
that naturally dissolves fear
and that muscle is the muscle of
information the muscle of education and
the muscle of skill set so if you know
more and then you develop the skill set
you won't be as afraid to do that thing
that you're talking about but the other
side to that now i'm going to disrupt
you a bit so the first part not so
disruptive that means go get more
information
give fear what fear needs to to to
reduce itself meaning information skill
set but this other part that i'm going
to tell you this might be disruptive
how about
you not try
to mitigate resolve or get past or
overcome whatever you want to call it
how about you not try to do that with
fear
how about you allow to fear to sit with
you you just commit to keep moving
even with the fear
so many times in my life and in my
career i was afraid
the difference between me and most is
that i still move forward with the fear
fear does not have a pass to stop you
fear does not have a pass to stop you
first of all let me just tell you this
just like compassion just like love
just like respect just like any other
feeling you feel for someone fear is
just a feeling we just give fear more
power we say when compassion comes i hug
i love when understanding comes when joy
comes when humor comes i laugh
but when fear comes i get to stop what
if you change the meaning to that oh
just just stick with me right here
what if
you change your dance with fear
what if you tell fear you're welcome
in my life because you're gonna come
can't keep you away
but when you come
i'm not going to stop
i might collect more information i might
get more team members i might get a
coach i might get on my knees and pray a
little harder longer but i will get up
and i will stay moving
see that's what i had to do not really
had i guess that's what i chose to do
well i felt like i had to do it because
i had this dream in my belly and it had
to come out i had to show the world who
i really was i had to see how big i can
play i had to see how jump how high i
could jump how fast i can run how many
people i could serve i had to
it was non-negotiable for me
and so when the fear rose and it rose i
mean it rose as a woman
out of south central l.a
not having a college degree teaching
these techniques it rose when i was the
only african-american inside a community
wanting to transform lives and learning
how to do you know different techniques
it rose when i started my company and
decided i want to share with the world
my dream it rose when my son's father
went to prison and stayed in prison over
20 years it rose when i wanted to be on
stage talking about transformation but i
was over 200 pounds it rolls it rolls it
rolls it rolls when i made a lot of
money
and then it rolls and i lost a lot of
money
and it rolls when i did that again and
again and again
it kept coming
at some point i said okay
i will not wait for you to go away
i will learn how to dance with you
can you feel the fear
hold the fear in one hand
and hold your passion in the other
and can you take them both and allow
them to coexist and you still show up
and play full out
because if you can do that
if you choose not can if you choose to
transform your relationship with fear
that fear is just an informant it's not
a hurdle it's not a block it's not a
wall
fear is an informant it says go get
something get more rest get more people
get more information get more skill set
go get something
and you can still go
you can get that thing
and keep going
then you won't ever wonder
you won't ever wonder how to overcome
fear again
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four is don't give up
with guru paul das have you ever felt
like you wanted to give up because
things are not going at your expected
pace have you ever felt like
leaving what you're doing because you
see no growth
have you ever felt like ending at all
because of failures you have experienced
on your path
well
whenever you feel low depressed and
overwhelmed with negative emotions
because of the ups and downs that
inevitably come in life whenever you
feel like you want to quit whenever you
are just not able to see a reason to
continue living
do remind yourself
of a simple
yet profound analogy
it's been one of my favorites from the
very first time i heard it
a man planted
fern
and bamboo seeds and cared for them
really well he made sure that they both
got adequate light and water
the man was delighted to see the fern
quickly spring out from the earth and
grow
really fast covering its entire
surrounding with its bright green color
but he was disappointed when he saw
nothing come out from the bamboo seed
but the man
did not give up on the battle
in the second year he saw that the
growth of the fern was luxuried vibrant
and abundant at the bamboo seed
nothing came out still
but the man continued caring for the
bamboo and did not quit
in the third year there was still
nothing from the bamboo seed and the man
still would not give up
in the fourth year
once again
he saw
nothing come from the bamboo sea
but the man received
and still
would not quit
it was in the
fifth year
that the man saw a tiny sprout
emerge from the earth the bamboo sprout
was tiny and insignificant compared to
the fan but in just six months from then
the bamboo shot up
to 100 feet tall
the man realized that the bamboo had
spent those five years
growing its roots
it was those roots that made it strong
and gave it all what it needed to
survive thrive and grow
isn't it true that life does not give
anyone
a challenge
that they cannot handle
if there's a challenge that you are
facing at the moment
know for sure
that you have the capacity to handle it
were you aware that all the time you
have spent
dealing with your challenges and
struggles
you've actually been growing
roots
just as the man did not give up on the
bamboo
don't give up on yourself
never quit
don't compare yourself to others the
bamboo and the fern are so different
yet
both make the forest
beautiful
each one serving a different purpose
relax
your time will come
you will shoot up and rise high as well
go as high as you can
as high as your potential not someone
else's potential be patient and keep
working on yourself and one day you will
shoot up like the bamboo tree too
remember that london is five hours ahead
of new york but that doesn't make new
york slow
or london fast
everything in life happens at the right
time be patient and the right time will
come for you as well
don't hurry
and
don't worry
you're neither early
nor are you too late you're just
on
time rule number five is move from
failure to failure with russell brand
did you see that tweet where someone
asked me to talk about failure well here
i am talking about failure now i've
failed a lot in my life most notably the
thing that comes to mind and by god i
wish it didn't was
my expectations around the success of
the film arthur that i appeared in and
then the reality of the film arthur that
i appeared in
it didn't do well and afterwards i felt
uh eviscerated so that showed me
it took a long time to see this that i
really wrapped up my sense of self in
personal success that i thought that if
arthur is like a number one
box office smash then i will be enough i
will be validated and valuable
i was shown that by attaching my sense
of self to that particular endeavor
that i was going to suffer
now what i've learned through continual
failure some that preceded that and some
that have come subsequent to it
is that the less external things that i
rely on
the better
and that the process of failure is a
process of education of realizing that
failure is a situation
labeled as a negative situation only by
my own desires and it's often not the
external situation that needs to change
but my attitude towards it
i've failed in relationships before i've
failed professionally before i've failed
in my expectations of myself
and where that's brought me to
is a kind of willingness to acknowledge
and accept that i don't know what's best
for me
that's vital in recovery to arrive at
the point where you realize that your
own vision of reality cannot be a
determiner
you become teachable when you know that
also it's good to know that no
external thing will ever be sufficient
to make me okay with the world
and
also it's difficult to uh understand the
effect of time you know like when that
happened when uh like arthur didn't go
as well and i'm imagining people in
genuine crisis watching this oh you poor
man a film didn't do as well as you
hoped it would you know like i'm aware
of the
depth and breadth of suffering that's
available i'm aware of the pain that
people go through some
somewhat because i remember it but
mainly because i listen and am aware
that some people's sense of failure is
as a parent because they've lost their
children some people sense of failures
as a husband because they've lost their
partner
but for me the
what is common to all forms of failure
wherever it lands on the scale
is
that the possibility for us to change
our perspective
what's quite uh holistic about
what i have been taught
is being willing to let go of the idea
that i know what's best for me
and now
i realize that because i've been removed
from a particular career path due to a
circumstance a world of possibility has
opened up to me because i'm happy with
the person i am now because i'm happy in
my relationship because i love my
children because i love my life because
i see the possibility for a beautiful
future where i am valuable and of
service where i'm truly connected to
people
things that are regarded as a failure in
the past
it just seemed like
necessary parts of a journey
so when you feel like you are failing if
you feel like you're failing at work or
you feel like you're failing in your
marriage i suppose i would invite you to
consider that it's possible that you do
not yet have all of the information
from moment to moment we travel through
life with our limited perspective
whether that's in the visual field or
the field of consciousness we're not
capable of understanding the
entire sphere of our reality but
generally more will be revealed to us
and
broadly what i think will be revealed to
you is that what you have once regarded
as failure is a necessary step on your
journey to becoming the person you were
intended to be rule number six is turn
failure into positive with jocko willing
i'm a huge fan of the podcast and i'd
like your advice
when i was younger
i joined the national guard in an
attempt to do something with my life and
get out of depression
i lost my discipline and goals after
basic training and continued in
depression and
disorganization i had the opportunity to
go to fight to flight school but instead
tested positive on a drug test
and i was given a general discharge i of
course take full responsibility and feel
like an idiot how would you recommend
moving past this failure
what would you have done if your seal
career ended with a mistake
well if my seal career had ended with a
mistake i would have figured out what my
next mission was going to be
that's that's what i would have done
i mean i would have said okay i like
that job i failed at it
what can i learn from that and what can
i do
next differently to make sure i don't
make that mistake again
i'm gonna learn from the past but i'm
not gonna dwell on it
there's no point in dwelling on it
the only point in dwelling on just to
learn from it so that's what i would do
here and then i would take what i
learned from my experiences of where i
failed
and i would also take the positive
things that i learned because you even
that even that failure is a positive
even that failure is a positive because
you realize you realize the value of the
opportunity that you had and you blew it
and you're like okay i'm never gonna let
that happen again lesson learned i'm
actually stoked i get to learn that
lesson
because there's gonna be more
opportunities that come up in life and
you gotta make sure that you don't
disregard those opportunities when they
come up
and i so i would have taken those
lessons learned take that take that
failure and turn it into something
positive and made good things happen
when i figured out what my new
mission and new career was going to be
pretty straightforward
you can you can do so much good and you
know that's going back to the story that
i told about uh jeff in the beginning of
this podcast
one of the
wording some of the wording that i
struggled with
in the kids story and again it's on it's
the warrior kid podcast
one of the things that i struggled with
in telling the story was
i ended up saying
jeff had gone too far and he couldn't
correct himself
yeah he had gone too far and he couldn't
come back
and that's a real hard thing to tell a
person
and it's a real hard thing to tell a kid
and the reason why i left it that way
the reason why i kept it like listen
you can make mistakes that you can't
come back from especially as a kid you
can make mistakes that you can't come
back from they're pretty rare
right there's not too many mistakes that
are so grievous that you can't recover
from them like this guy
hey man he made a mistake failed a drug
test given a general discharge that
sucks
guess what he can do all kinds of good
in the world he can make up for that
tenfold he can start a business make
money he can create a family he can
raise great kids and there's so many
things that he can make sure his kids
understand that and know that and learn
from it and he can make sure some other
neighborhood kids and high school kids
and grade school kids he can make such
an impact on the world by learning from
that mistake
so it's very it's a harsh thing to say
like hey
there's some things you can't now what
this guy can't recover from
and this is what this is the f uh fact
that you have to face and this is why i
told it this way in the kids story
he didn't understand when he made that
mistake he didn't understand that
there's some mistakes you cannot recover
from he can't be a pilot now
it's not going to happen zero chance of
him being a military pilot that's the
way it works
so if i would have had the opportunity
to tell him when he was 13 years old hey
listen bro
i get it you're going to step outside
the box sometimes but there's some
mistakes that you can make that you'll
never be able to recover from so think
about what you're doing before you do
them you need to think about what you're
doing before you do them
and if i would have had the opportunity
to tell him that when he was 13 years
old he might have had a better
decision-making process when he got
older that's why i left it that way for
those kids so that they recognize that
there are some things that you do as a
as a person as a kid that you cannot
recover from you cannot recover from
them
now that being said when you take this
and you put it in perspective as an
adult see and as an adult you have a
much broader world to be a part of
and just because he's not going to be a
pilot a military pilot by the way
just because he's not going to be a
military pilot there's all kinds of
other opportunities out there and you
can explain that to an adult but it's
hard to explain that to a kid
so what other opportunities i mean even
if especially like oh you want to be a
pilot cool you can become a civilian
pilot and you can you know you can fly
you can make things happen that way
but
what we're not going to do and what i
would not do
is dwell on the past and dwell on what
the mid the big missed opportunity is
because guess what that's that's a
missed opportunity that there's all
kinds of people in the world would love
for that to be their biggest mistake
that they've made that's that's it they
would love there's someone sitting in
prison right now that's like man i wish
all i did was get a fail a drug test and
i could have learned my lesson instead
i'm sitting here in prison
or i got injured
really bad because i did something that
i shouldn't have done or i made a bad
decision or i got someone that i'd care
about hurt or injured because i took him
in a in a car when i was drunk
like those are the kind of mistakes this
mistake
sure it's a bummer guess what there are
infinitely infinitely worse mistakes
that he could have made infinitely worse
so
you're all right man
you're okay
learn from it don't dwell on it move on
and go go do something really positive
in the world rule number seven is fail
big with denzel washington i was
flunking out of college
i had a 1.7 grade point average
i hope none of you can relate
at a 1.7 grade point average
i was sitting in my mother's beauty shop
they still call it beauty shops now what
they call it yeah i sit in the beauty
parlor i was sitting in my mother's
beauty parlor
and i'm looking in the mirror and i see
behind me this woman under the dryer
and every time she looked up she every
time i looked up she was looking at me
just looking me in the eye i didn't know
who she was and i said you know
she said somebody give me a pen give me
a pencil i have a prophecy
march 27 1975 she said boy you are going
to travel the world
and speak to millions of people
now mind you i flunked out of college
i'm thinking about joining the army i
didn't know what i was going to do and
she's telling me i'm going to travel the
world
and speak to millions of people
well i have traveled the world
and i have spoke to millions of people
but that's not the most important thing
the success that i had the most
important thing is that what she taught
me and what she told me that day has
stayed with me since
i've been protected
i've been directed
i've been corrected
fail
big
that's right
fail big
you only live once
so do what you feel passionate about
passionate about
take chances
professionally
don't be afraid to fail there's an old
iq test was nine dots
and you had to
draw five lines with a pencil within
these nine dots
without lifting the pencil
the only way to do it was to go outside
the box
so don't be afraid to go outside the box
don't be afraid to
think outside the box don't be afraid to
fail
big
to dream
big but remember
dreams
without goals
are just dreams
and they ultimately fuel
disappointment
so have dreams
but have goals
life goals
yearly goals
monthly goals daily goals
i try to give myself a goal
every day
and understand
that to achieve these goals
you must apply discipline
and consistency
you have to work at it
every day you have to plan
every day you've heard the saying we
don't
plan to fail
we fail to plan
hard work
works
working really hard
is what successful people do
and in this
text
tweet
twerk world that you've grown up in
remember just because
you're doing a lot more
doesn't mean you're getting a lot more
done
[Music]
remember that just because you're doing
a lot more
doesn't mean you're getting a lot more
done
don't confuse
movement
with progress
my mother told me yeah cause you can run
in place all the time and never get
anywhere
so continue to strive continue to have
goals continue to
progress
and anything you want
good
you can have
[Music]
so claim it
work hard to get it
when you get it reach back
pull someone else up
each one
teach one
[Music]
don't just aspire to make a living
aspire to make a difference
and rule number eight the last one
before some very special bonus clips is
improve yourself with sad guru when
we're on this journey of life we tend to
set a lot of short-term goals and when
we don't
achieve them we don't know how to deal
with failure
and that is something we all deal with a
lot at u of t in specific but uh
but in that moment when
we can look back and say yeah this is
fine but in that moment how do we hold
our ground and how do we learn to see
the bigger picture
should i tell you about my failures
hello
no they're not interested
i have some friends who want to know
about my failure
[Laughter]
when i was 10 11
the only thing
that i had in my mind is i just want to
go somewhere i don't know where
so those days if i got five rupees
five rupees with lots of money i bought
a little bit of bread and disappeared
into the jungle
just walked around caught a bunch of
snakes i absorbed everything from
insects to worms to animals to
everything
and i ran out of food and became
difficult after three four five days
came back
by then there was a lot of unnecessary
excitement in the town
police complaints searching all over the
place
looking into the morgue
all kinds of things
and then i came back and they were all
listening but i left a note
they just ignore my words and do
everything else
so after a few times they got used to
that
[Music]
and i also grew up
[Music]
so i didn't know where but i just wanted
to go somewhere
all i knew was
somehow
the known situations was kind of
containing me
i just wanted to go somewhere
the moment i got a bicycle
i cycled across south india
and i got a motorcycle i criss crossed
india many times
and i was stopped at the national
borders
so i decided the only thing is i do some
business make some money and ride across
the world where i don't know simply want
to write
so i thought i'll get into business so i
got in
became far more successful than most
people would imagine in a short span of
time
so one to another i started half a dozen
businesses
became very successful everything
then
everybody was clapping their hands
except me
they were all clapping their hands
because i was making more money than
other people
i was getting little
like that because
i got into this business because i
wanted to ride away
but business after business i put one
finger now both my hands were stuck in
it
making money and everybody clapping
hands but
i was not clapping hands
i did not think it's a great thing i
think it's those five years which people
think are very successful for me
were
the five years when
i did not do what i really wanted to do
[Music]
but everybody else thought i was doing
great
that's how well it is you must
understand
when you're doing great they think
you're doing no good
when you think you're doing no good they
all think you're doing great
so you must know whose interest is in
their hearts
so then one afternoon it so happened i
burst into an ecstatic state for no
reason every cell in my body bursting
and then i look at myself what is
happening to me am i
going off my rocker
am i losing it what's happening
but i know i don't want to lose what's
happening because it's too fantastic if
i simply sit here i'm dripping ecstasy
then i pay attention to it what is it
that's happening to me then i realize
if i
don't mess with my mind
i'm just ecstatic
even now
just see
it's just
the cerebral activity that you're not
able to deal with isn't it which causes
so much all this
if you know how to distance yourself
from that
this life will burst into ecstatic state
when you are a five-year-old girl
simply jumping around
simply because there was a not much
cerebral activity
simply life was a joy just to be alive
isn't it
even now you will become like that if
you know
when to
keep your cerebral activity
on when to keep it off
when i realized if you don't do anything
you will become ecstatic then i thought
what's the big deal
i will make the whole world ecstatic
on that day the world's population was
5.6 billion people
then i sat down and made an elaborate
plan
how
i will make the world ecstatic
because it's so simple
if they don't do anything they will be
ecstatic
i didn't think
people are so invested in misery
that it will take a lot of coaxing
then i made a plan in two and a half
years time
i can very easily make the world
ecstatic
i thought i will execute this plan
because you are a consulting business
person i am telling you
i had everything clear cut
because this is this simple
if i talk to them why will they deny
ecstasy
[Music]
they will all go for it
38 years
don't do this
you're clapping at my failures
so people today say we have touched
somewhere between 800 to 900 million
people
but that's not my idea of the world
population has grown to 7.6 billion
people
now i know i will die of failure
but i am a blissful failure
[Music]
okay
because
first is i learned how to fix myself
before i do anything in the world
if you fix yourself will you fix
yourself in a pleasant way or unpleasant
way
pleasant way so if you become joyful by
your own nature
then you do something in the world
[Music]
depending upon the times in which we
exist we must understand this never
underestimate this depending upon the
times in which we exist we do certain
things our world allows us to do certain
things isn't it
today you're in your university all of
you here
because this is 21st century
if this was 12th century
uh maybe you would be fighting a war
maybe you would blowing the land maybe
you would be doing something else so you
being a university is not your
achievement it is the times
you have some role
you have a stake in it but
it is the times which is allowing you to
do this isn't it
historically at what time we are born
is deciding most of what we do so do not
make that a big affair
first and foremost thing is to grow this
one this piece of life to its highest
possibility
if you grow this one to a certain level
of capability competence and well-being
this will do something in this world
according to the times
instead of that what you are trying to
do is you are trying to upgrade your
activity
without upgrading the machine
[Music]
it is like you took an old beat-up
pickup truck i won't name the brand
because they're just across the great
lakes
you
you took one old beat up truck pickup
truck you have but you suddenly got a
desire you want to go into the formula
one racing
you went
now your four wheels will be going in
four different directions
you want to get onto the track
at least to buy a standard ferrari
hello
if you have an upgraded machine
is your activity naturally upgraded i'm
asking you
but without upgrading the machine if you
upgrade activity
upgraded activity is creating enormous
suffering isn't it
see those of you who are thinking it's
very hard to be in the university
i can take you back home and make you
plow the land
very easy
you don't know what it is
so i'm not trying to make fun of things
but i want you to
understand the privilege of being in the
times in which you are
where our survival process is better
organized than ever before in the
history of humanity yes
[Music]
yes or no
are you materially not living better
than your parents and grandparents
unless
your father was a maharaja in india or
something no you're common
so definitely you're living better than
them isn't it especially all of you
young women who are here i want you to
acknowledge this
that
this is the best time
to be a woman on this planet it never
was this good
well
still there are issues which we have to
improve no question about that
but isn't it better than ever before
if we do not acknowledge
what we have we will not create what we
want just know this
it's only a failure if you quit it's
only a failure if you stop it's only a
failure if you throw in a towel and say
i'm done if you still love it and you
give up that's when it's a failure
otherwise
it's a speed bump otherwise it's a
learning opportunity otherwise it's
motivation to help you keep going as
long as you love doing it you have to
keep going the biggest
potential failure that i had was when i
quit on my business partner i was in my
i was 19
um
20 i was struggling with my company
you've seen no results
pouring just so much into my company
every day and not getting any anything
any traction anything we just we were
not winning
and you know you have those moments
where
you just feel like
you're not valuable anymore it's one
thing if you're working
and you're getting results but when
you're when you're working and not
getting results
you get really frustrated if you're not
working and you're not getting results
you can you can say okay that's fine you
know there's lots of things i didn't
work hard at and i didn't get results so
it's fine but when you're working hard
every day just not seeing results
i think there's only so long that you
can last before you start to feel
really bad about yourself
and so i i quit on my business partner
and i couldn't believe that i said those
words
i couldn't believe that i was saying i
quit on something that i cared so deeply
about and i cried
and cried and cried and cried and barely
slept that night and decided the next
day i can't quit yet i can't quit yet
there's i just have to find another way
to stand i had the words of oprah in my
head saying
you have to find another way to stand
don't quit
and that's what led me to modern success
and that's what led me to building my
business and making that first sale to
then selling the whole business and then
launch my website and launch my youtube
channel the frustration and the
negativity and the low of saying i quit
leading to the worst moment of my life
feeling like a total piece of garbage as
a human
then led to the the greatest
breakthrough
of all time for me which was to model
success it forced me to think of well i
can't keep doing it the way i'm doing it
i can't keep going like this because
this obviously is not working
i have to find another way to stand
maybe i'm not the first guy to try to
figure this out
in that moment of desperation i asked
that question maybe i'm not the first
guy to figure this out who has done this
and in modeling bill gates that saved my
company and i've been doing it for the
last 20 years now modeling success
finding the people who have done the
things that i want to do
done the things that you want to do and
sharing their lessons
so it's not only
a speed bump
that that failure
that setback of me saying i quit
actually led to the greatest
breakthrough of all time for evan
carmichael the human the lowest moment
in my life led to the greatest moment of
all time the greatest insight the
greatest unlock
of all time
failure is only real failure
if you quit
if you give up and you throw in the
towel on the thing that you care about
so how do we start to move through it
how do you start to see those rejections
and those failures as just road bumps or
potential catapults forward well a
couple things three ideas number one
start small
where so many entrepreneurs get it wrong
is you try to go big out of the gate i
love dreaming big dream big is great
that's that's going to keep you
motivated inspired energetic willing to
chase down your goals dream big yes
forever and
act small
start small find a small way to start
right now today that huge idea that
you've got
what's the fastest path that's inside of
your big vision that can get you to some
revenue that can get you to some cash
flow what's the fastest path to do that
that's in alignment still with your big
mission
so often entrepreneurs try to go big too
soon
and you take out the mortgage on the
house you spend your entire life savings
on this new idea and if it doesn't work
then you're a failure then you have no
other options you have no plan b you
have no shot to actually go
and turn another company around
where what you want to do is find the
smallest foster way to get started and
just start
just start because your perfect plan
isn't going to be perfect if you
mortgage your home and take out a giant
loan to launch your first business and
you've never done it before you're
probably going to make tons of mistakes
and any of those mistakes might sink the
company because they're big mistakes
but if you're starting small any one
little mistake it's just a little
mistake it doesn't sink the company
doesn't sink your idea and you're still
able to show up for another day
so whatever your big idea is start small
dream big
act small
the smallest possible way from your idea
to just take one little step forward
today and another the next day and
another the next day
you flip that thinking you'll start to
see a lot more momentum in your business
number two expect to fail at the
beginning
expect to fail this is another big
reason why entrepreneurs don't win and
don't stay on it because they expect it
to be great out of the gate
i've got a great idea i want to serve i
think it's going to help a lot of people
boom this is a winning idea and then
when it doesn't work right away you get
frustrated because the expectations that
you had for how well it would do
do not actually line up to the results
at the beginning expect a fail
expect everything to go wrong when i
make a video expect to suck i tell
people this inside my movement makers
program where i'm training people to be
thought leaders
we have a hundred video challenge where
i want you to make 100 videos before you
tell yourself that you suck
because what ends up happening is you
may not think you're going to be great
you know you're not going to be
some amazing superstar in front of the
camera the first time out but you expect
to be
decent
and then you film yourself and you watch
your back and you realize wow i'm way
worse
than i ever thought it was going to be
have you had that experience you thought
you were going to be maybe not world
class we thought you were going to be
pretty good and then you do the thing
and you're just way way way worse
you go ice skating or riding the bike or
snowboarding or something you think okay
it doesn't look that hard and you get on
and you're falling all over the place
have you had that experience the problem
is then people quit too soon
so why we have 100 video challenges
before you quit and say that you suck at
video and it's just not meant for you
and it's not the thing that you should
be doing
do 100 videos
and see yourself get better
and people are already commenting after
the fifth video the 10th video the 20th
video the 30th video how much they've
already grown and learned and improved
and gotten better and look back on their
first rate and say wow that was so bad
but look how much i've already grown
when you expect to be great out of the
gate and you're not then people never
want to show up again
you never want to do it again but when
you expect to suck and then and then you
do suck and you're a little bit better
every day
it gives you the permission
to fail
and it gives you the permission to show
up again and fail a little bit less
because all you're really missing is
momentum and then tip number three is
find another way to stand the classic
advice from oprah winfrey that saved my
business and might save yours as well is
if you really really love doing it and
it's just not working out find another
way to stand find another way to keep
going find another way to do something
model the success of somebody who's come
before you ask for help
share your story find another way to
stand because if you quit now
if you quit and you don't love it that's
fine
you should quit if you don't love
something i think a lot of entrepreneurs
stay in a business stay in a
relationship stay in something for too
long just out of expectations and they
actually stopped loving it two years ago
you should have quit a long time ago
if you don't love it quit right now
immediately that's not a failure the
failure of staying in this thing that
you don't love because you'll never do
great work inside of something that you
don't love
but if you still love it
if you still get excited by it if still
enjoy the process if you still want to
do this thing and see it through and
serve people make the impact that you
know you're capable of having that if
that's still inside you
[Music]
and you quit today
you're going to regret that decision for
the rest of your life
you're going to look back on your life
at this moment and say i wish i gave it
one more day i wish i gave it one more
week i wish i gave it one more month i
wish i just gave it a little bit more i
had it in me i could have done it and i
didn't because i was afraid because i
was tired because i was fed up
and now i regret
not taking my shot i had a chance i had
my shot back then and i didn't do it
don't be that person
if you still love it
if you still are addicted to it you
still want to have that impact that you
know you're capable of having inside
this business
don't quit
just find a different way to save it
people are just afraid man so many
people are afraid of rejection of
failure but without failure you have no
success what was the one that stung the
most as far as failures was stunned the
most biggest failure i had a tv show
called the big house got picked up by
abc they told me that we were gonna do
12 episodes flew me down to new york
um this is the biggest news ever i'm
about to be rich holy sh i'm 22. i got a
tv show i'm writing
executive producing starring in the show
you know what no i'm not just gonna go
down there by myself we gotta bring the
cast they said nope kevin we only flying
you i said well i'ma pay for the cast to
come i took my own money flew em all
down in new york get to new york
put on my suit people taking pictures of
me walking out this is the best thing
ever holy sh i'm famous this is what it
is i get to the upfronts up front to
where they announce your tv show it's a
slew of shows they're announcing their
time slots i'm next they're about to
announce the big house somebody puts
their hand on my chest and says kevin
wait they talking the earpiece they said
nope i'm standing with him right now i'm
like what's going on what do they want
me to do you know they want me going the
other side or something
he goes
okay i'll tell them they canceled
they're not gonna pick you up uh you
gotta step back and i was like wait that
don't sound right literally that fast
they sent me home they were like you
gotta just go home tv show got picked up
six months later for six episodes
the third episodes aired they canceled
the show again i got the show cantu
twice
in a six month period which has never
been done before i booked about three
more pilots
got cancelled there was a show called
john stamos's show he was a publicist
and they wanted me as a series regular
the show was going great ratings were
good put me on the show show got
cancelled
it was everything i touched on tv
turned
i'm now just sitting out here doing
nothing i had no money uh borrowing
money left and right i decided to say it
i said i'm just gonna do stand-up comedy
and focus on my craft and i slaved the
road for about five years doing the same
circuit over and over again and let me
tell you you should feel so proud
of making it to this day
and i hope
that you're excited to get started on
that next chapter
but i also imagine that
you might think about all that history
all those heroes who came before you and
you might also feel a little pressure
you know
pressure to live up
to the legacy of those who came before
you
pressure to meet the expectations of
others
and believe me i understand that kind of
pressure
i've experienced a little bit of it
myself
you see graduates
i didn't start out as the fully firm
formed first lady who stands before you
today no no i had my share of bumps
along the way
back when my husband first started
campaigning for president folkes had all
sorts of questions of me
what kind of first lady would i be
what kinds of issues would i take on
would i be more like laura bush or
hillary clinton or nancy reagan
and the truth is those same questions
would have been posed to any candidate
spouse that's just the way the process
works
but as potentially the first
african-american first lady
i was also the focus of another set of
questions and speculations
conversations sometimes rooted in the
fears and misperceptions of others
was i too loud or too angry or too
emasculating
or
was i too soft
too much of a mom not enough of a career
woman
then there was the first time i was
on a magazine cover
it was a cartoon drawing of me with a
huge afro and a machine gun
now
yeah i wish satire
but if i'm really being honest
that knocked me back a bit
it made me wonder well
just how are people seeing me
or you might remember the on stage
celebratory fist bump between me and my
husband after a primary win that was
referred to as a terrorist fist jab
and over the years folks have used
plenty of interesting words to describe
me
one said i
exhibited a little bit of uppity-ism
another noted that i was one of my
husband's cronies of color
cable news charmingly referred to me as
obama's baby mama
and of course barack has endured his
fair share of insults and slights
even today
there are still folks
questioning his citizenship
and all of this
used to really get to me
back in those days i had a lot of
sleepless nights worrying about what
people thought of me
wondering if i might be hurting my
husband's chances of winning his
election
fearing how my girls would feel if they
found out what some people were saying
about their mom
but eventually
i realized that if i wanted to keep my
sanity
and not let others define me
there was only one thing i could do
and that was to have faith in god's plan
for me
i had to ignore all of the noise
and be true to myself
and the rest would work itself out when
i was 29
i told myself
the next acting job i get no matter what
it pays i will from now on
for better or worse
be a working actor
so i quit my position at the
professional examination services
my friends really weren't happy about
that because it was so easy to find me
when i worked there work was that was
the only place i had the internet this
was at the beginning of the internet
and now i didn't have either the
internet or a cell phone or a job
but something good
happened got a low paying theater job in
a play called imperfect love
which led to a film called 13 moons with
the same writer
which led to other roles which led to
other roles
and i've worked as an actor ever since
[Applause]
but
i didn't know that would happen
at 29
walking away from data processing
i was terrified
10 years in a place without heat six
years at a job i felt stuck in
maybe i was afraid of change
are you
my parents didn't have much money
but they struggled
to send me to the best schools
and one of the most important things
they did for me
and graduates maybe you don't want to
hear this
is that once i graduated
i was on my own
financially it was my turn
[Applause]
parents are applauding
graduates are not
but this made me very hungry
literally
i couldn't be lazy
now i'm totally lazy but back then
i couldn't be
and so at 29
and a very long last i was in the
company of the actors and writers and
directors i'd sought out that first year
that first day
after school
i was i am by their sides
raise the rest of your life
to meet you
don't search for defining moments
because they will never come the world
might say you are not allowed to yet
i waited a long time out in the world
before i gave myself permission to fail
please
don't even bother asking
don't bother telling the world you are
ready
show it
do it
what did beckett say
ever tried ever failed
no matter
try again
fail again
fail
better because you made it this far in a
video i want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe nation you made it here
all the way to the end and i love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
below on this video i will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome if you want to learn to push
through the hard times with jordan
peterson check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there stop doing the things that you
know are wrong
that you could stop doing if you're
failing repeatedly it's possible that
there's something wrong with the way
that you're conceptualizing the world